there are a lot of promises in the stem
cell field but all of them are failing
in the clinic if you read those
literature's they have one thing in
common the cells after transplantation
didn't survive the major reason for that
was they were not in the right
environment of the micro environment
where they can survive and then do the
job they were sent in for let's create a
micro environment so that the cells once
transplanted they should be there and
then do their job we specialize there in
engineering the matrix in a tissue
specific manner so the first one we have
designed it is designed for the brain so
we have tuned the stiffness the porosity
of the matrix to a level that matches
the compliance of the brain and so when
they are cultured in mg/l this matrix
the field that they're in a brain like
environment and that's why they become
new
[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to a
simulation we are back at Indy bio demo
day we are talking to super deep das hi
thanks for joining us coming on the show
thank you appreciate Congrats on demo
day convalesce that's great convalesce
convalesce so brain like
microenvironments mhm
this is this is some weird stuff that i
haven't heard of yet so let's learn
let's unpack this and talk about it on
the way to that I want to learn more
about who you are and how you even got
here so okay how'd you even get to the
point of making these making this
company okay um so this started as my
PhD project and back then I was
interested in solving the science
problem because there was a huge
spending problem in the stem cell field
that there are a lot of promises in the
stem cell field but all of them are
failing in the clinic and if you read
those literature's they have one thing
in common which is the cells after
transplantation didn't survive and the
major reason for that was they were not
in the right environment of the micro
environment where they can live or they
can survive and then do the job they
were sent in for and then it started
that okay let's create a micro
environment so that the cells once
transplanted they should be there and
then do their job okay so the cells
being transplanted and then dying was
the problem and then the solution is
creating a micro environment that makes
the cells live when they get
transplanted now okay does this work for
all different cells that they don't need
different micro environments they didn't
need and okay
of course they need because if you think
about just think about your different
organs every organ has two critical
things one is the cells of this organ
like your heart cell and your kidney
cells are differential but what people
do not
get it obvious is that the matrix of
kidney and heart is also different and
we specialize there in engineering the
matrix in a tissue specific manner so
the first one we have designed it is
designed for the brain so we have tuned
the stiffness the porosity of the matrix
to a level that matches the compliance
of the brain and so stem cells are
mechanosensitive and so when they are
cultured in mg/l this matrix the field
that they're in a brain like environment
and that's why they become neuron okay
so this is the M gel matrix is your yes
proprietary exactly okay so so then this
am gel matrix is going to change for
brain versus heart versus kidney cuz
it's just gonna need to be a different
pressure and porosity if they're saying
yep okay and then within the is there is
what about the X like what about the
external variable so even though the am
gel a and am joe yeah I am gel is even
though that is a certain proprietary
assemblage of yours what about the like
externalities is it just like you know
you know vacuum or what is it in to
prevent I guess what are the other
variables that you have to account for
as you grow the cells as you transplant
this okay so they're if you so what we
do is our approach is when you think of
engineering a particular matrix we start
looking at the natural organ which is
present in the human body and then what
are the components of those matrix like
what kind of substrate there is always a
base matrix and then what we have we
have mimicked that base matrix using
some self-assembled peptides and then we
add complexities like tissue specific
tissue specific factors this could be
biochemical factors it could be other
extracellular fact factors that are
required and that are exclusive to one
particular tissue and then we add those
components to our matrix in a specific
time of the matrix generation so that
they get incorporated within the matrix
and then when you culture cells on them
the cells take very specific cues from
the Mary's yes the metrics are kind of
like the variables of the environment
that the brain is yes okay so you take
in and you kind of if you take all you
understand the variables of the brain
environment and then you bring it into a
and M gel am gel external from from the
brain into an environment and then those
that then is able to house and grow the
stem cells now what is the prime is this
being like what is this
neurodegenerative disease is the main
like when do I want to grow more
neuronal yeah so the target is that the
brain where what happens if you lose
those neurons and the diseases that we
are targeting say for parkinson's
neurons in a specific region of the
brain they die and once they're dead the
system is not capable of regenerating or
regenerating those lost neurons so again
that's because the micro environment of
those that disease region is not
suitable for a regeneration so what we
are doing giving is an assisted
regeneration yes so you put the stem
cells mixed with the angel' in the very
specific region you want the cells to
grow and the cells will stay there and
grow into the target neuron type you
want so do I need to take a stem cells
from my brain to be able to no we we so
now you're talking about which type of
stem cells to use for an effective
therapy okay and there are multiple
types of stem cells like it could be
derived from your bone marrow
it could be derived from yours your skin
cells and reprogrammed what we call
eyepieces
and we have suggested that it works for
a wide variety of stem cells but then
needs to go back into
Parkinson's is yes killed in my brain
yes exactly but then how do you
administer it to go back to our
apartment since so your brain is there
is a 3d map of your brain so doctors can
tell from scans that okay this is the
region where the degeneration is and
then in that region the cells could be
delivered using the am gel via what we
call a stereotactic surgery so
stereotactic surgery really targeted
surgery so there is there like
longitudes and latitudes of your brain
and then they can calculate okay that
this much distance from the exact
position but then how do they put it in
so they drill a hole in the skull and
then but that's again I'm telling you
that's a minimally invasive procedure
you don't have to open the skull that's
that's very small just a mall drill just
good enough for a needle to go in and
you know goes in here jumps off the Lord
the Lord yeah which is a which is in the
stencil mixed in MGM John yeah it's time
so mrs. Angela Wow and you can take it
from either like skin or bone marrow it
doesn't need a come from them no doesn't
it have to come from the brain because
yeah because it's like we do prefer
certain types of stem cells but the
thing is that we are optimizing
protocols for each type of stem cells
because this the stem cells that idea
from where bone marrow follows a
particular pattern of differentiation or
drawing into neurons so the formulation
is a bit different if it's a bone marrow
drive cell the formulation will be a
little bit different if it's an IPS see
that kind of thing yeah you can the bone
marrow or the
skin stem so can that make a heart cell
as well or kidney so to me yes yes yes
yes that's why you need a state foster
manipulation of those cells because the
last thing you would want is a kidney
growing in your brain so yeah so it's
like you have to control the fate of the
cells in such a controlled manner that
you know that yes this is what it is
going to be that that's an object so
then so you manufacture the EM gel and
then do you sell that do you also take
the do you also take them the stem cells
and bone marrow or skin cell and then
add it in and then make sure it works
and then do you use do you sell what
would part of the processor so we we are
our aim is to provide the complete
therapy it's like from start to finish
yeah from start to finish because you
actually yep the neurosurgeons does that
for us
so the the target is that it will so a
patient comes in gets enrolled comes to
the hospital the doctors to the scan and
then based on the situation if the
doctor feels that a stem cell
transplantation is required or maybe
beneficial for the patient then he or
she recommends a stem cell
transplantation then then we come to
know they're all gay such and such
patient in such and such Hospital
requires stem cell transplantation we
send them the file of cells and the vial
of gel so what is done is those are
mixed and then the surgeon performs the
surgery to transplant the cell and then
the patient goes off oh man okay so this
is first through Parkinson's is the big
yeah there's a big target yeah it's like
a couple million people per year
Parkinson's there are ten million people
worldwide suffering from Parkinson's in
you in the US every year sixty thousand
people are diagnosed with PD every year
like new new patients but I think this
this therapy will be primarily for the
patients which are not responding
the current treatment because the
current treatment just gives symptomatic
relief the doctor gives you recommends
you levered up our dopamine precursors
but eventually it's a progressive
neurodegenerative disease so it means
that you are losing every day losing
those some new runs every day losing
your life every day and that cannot be
reversed unless and until you have new
neurons in the brain are you also ready
to just continuously over time just
continue adding as the brain degenerates
can you just continue adding new yeah so
right now we what we're aiming is to see
the efficacy of a single shot because
that would be of course better that you
don't have to take it like okay maybe a
one shot 5s later another shot we want
to give a single shot and and make it
effective so on animal models we are
right now optimizing the the best shot
to so that we can have an idea of that
what kind of lesion size could be
managed with how many number of cells
those kind of thing and then what does
what does the next steps look like for
you to get this into the hands of PD
well now we we have done most of the
basic science it's it's torille and it
has shown efficacy in animal models the
next step is to do some of the GLP study
for talks which will enable us to file
our IND to the FDA and then so our next
immediate milestone is to check first
the the safety in human patients that's
what we will do in our phase 1 trial and
then we can we might have secondary
endpoints from there to understand that
if that what kind of efficacy the
transplants are giving but first of all
it would be just a safety study to see
whether it and that's why we are working
with these neurosurgeons who are
advising us on
the writing down the protocols that what
kind of protocol should be there what
should be the the clinical endpoints and
all this kind of things
and then what is one more time on the
a.m. gel is made of you Center your
peptides okay see you've figured out how
to make the specific so it's a specific
sequence and once you give a trigger
those peptides start assembling and they
develop into nano fibers and once the
nano fiber reaches beyond a critical
concentration it interacts the solvent
and give you a gel and that gel now you
can alter the properties of the gel by
adding or removing components before
inducing the generation so there are a
lot of factors which you can control so
that you can tune the gel according to a
particular purpose
and then that's how it can potentially
work for the other audiences exactly
what else should we know mm-hmm what
else should we know before we come to a
close what else is important for us to
know about what you're building
think the we are starting with
Parkinson's but if we are able to
successfully demonstrate that it works
for one disease there it will open up
endless opportunities like subsequently
engineering matrices for different
indications where where you require cell
replacement and there are multiple
conditions not only in the brain in
other organs where if you replace those
damaged cells your body works far better
and you live a healthy life so it can
technically work for those we have to
just figure out the right composition of
the matrix for individual organs and
then is is the like just I'm just trying
to envision all the other targets for
this I'm also trying to envision the
actual like delivery of the gel neuron
into the mixture of the brain like the
dead neurons are to be able to deliver
your neuron and then to have that start
working but in a location where the you
know the dead ones are already
taking up space so once once they're
dead add in some of the conditions there
there are actually there they're lesions
they're actually voids because once
they're dead there are regions of the
brain which which are like that the
brain has its own immune cells which
comes into play and sort of cleans up
the region and then creates a scar in
the brain so we want to prevent that
once we know that okay this this is the
region right there there is a
degeneration so you can put yourself in
there because one once the cells are
gone from that region you can fill it up
and also another thing is that this
matrix this this has a very specific
property of self-healing which means
that when you are putting it it will
flow and go in as liquid but up after it
goes in it will fill up whatever white
space is there and then for mature
interest
I'm looking forward to seeing how this
this pans out this one's really
interesting it's so much different than
the other better to talk to you about
this is good it's good to be this
different and you're taking a big leap
yep like I like this I like this yeah
awesome this has been super fun yep and
also also another another thing which I
think another potential area is that we
might be able to be at a stage someday
that where we'll be able to make parts
of organs in a dish because if we
uncover that what's the exact
composition of those matrices and what
kind of cells to add to them to develop
parts of organs and we can do that as
well
yes that is that's very exciting no I
wonder where that ranks in deficit but
that's a different complete different
area totally different day but also that
I'm always very interested in biotech
when people are exploring different like
keys what's the golden one to like the
whole like even regeneration or maybe
like a degeneration of some other organs
yeah and so you know we have friends
that are you know printing the 3d or the
ideas when does it become completely
better to just try and get the Playstore
like we're also you know what are the
you know I was like other people are
doing with yeah anti-aging just trying
yeah you're out him just reverse the
aging process back to the youthful yeah
that states cuz like I'm always
wondering what the most optimal biotech
yeah yeah I think definitely the the
type of approaches I would say for
especially for organ generation everyone
has a different type of approach and I
think that's good because you don't know
which one will work in the more options
you have and maybe sometimes I think the
best thing works when you combine two
solutions and then get something oh wow
I didn't think about this super fun
thank you thank you for talking to us
we appreciate it best of luck as you
continue to grow yep impact thanks
everyone for tuning in
[Music]